quand l'hôpital général juif a été
agrandie en 2016
on a prévu l'ajout de plusieurs chambre
à pression négative
il ya toujours une succession dans la
chambre qui forcent leur ait filtré on
infiltre heures qui capte les virus en
fait cette erreur est évacué il n'est
pas dirigé dans l'institution et parce
que d'investir dans les cordes à ce qui
élimine les risques de contagion en
dehors il y à plus de 80 de ces chambres
dans tout l'hôpital dont 24 au 10e étage
du pavillon k et on a à l'urgence ce nom
soit dépensé chez nous sur tous les
étages mais cet été a aussi été
construits littéralement pour une prime
id l'unité abrite déjà des personnes
atteintes de maladies respiratoires
contagieux on a l'habitude des
précautions qui sont prises dans
l'antichambre mais depuis quelques
semaines on fait aussi des simulations
la préparation a aidé à diminuer le
niveau de stress
ils savent qu'elle que les équipements
sont disponibles pour eux 1 infirmière
ou un médecin ou être été un patient qui
a le profil 19
il va toujours y avoir comme une ombre
derrière cette personne aucune autre
infirmière qui va s'assurer qu'il n'y a
pas de contamination pour intervenir
auprès des patients infectés
le personnel disposera de masques n95 de
visière jaquette et gand approprié
rien à voir avec les images qui arrivent
de chine où le personnel traite des
malades dans des dortoirs pendant des
heures une autre contexte là on doit
protéger le travers de la santé au
maximum avec ce genre de scaffa entre
lola la bible alors qu'ici au québec
qu'on va avoir un patient hospitalisé
par chambre une chambre avec un système
de ventilation extrêmement efficace qui
enlève toutes les particules
infectieuses à toutes les cinq minutes
on dit avoir tout prévu
selon différents scénarios ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'en date
d'aujourd'hui on a suffisamment de
ventilateurs et de lits en soins
intensifs pour pouvoir accueillir
plusieurs patients atteints du coville
qui auraient besoin d'être mis sous
respirateur c'est le ministère de la
santé qui coordonne les efforts et
qu'ils les adaptera la situation le
grand défi c'est que pour admettre des
patients pour le coc vide il faut
faire de la place pour ces passionnantes
à ce moment-là ça met une pression
supplémentaire sur le reste du réseau
mais l'hôpital n'est pas la porte
d'entrée pour les personnes qui ont des
symptômes
c'est d'abord au 8-1-1 qu'il faut
s'adresser ici anne louise despatie
radio canada montréal